he coveted host Super Bowl timeslot like
first of all how cool is that
yeah I heard they they would just play
this little football game before before
our show it was like this little intro
it's awesome that is Corey Hawkins
talking about the premiere of his new
show 24 legacy which is an evolution of
the 24 series it hits the air six years
after the original and that has lots of
people speculating on how in the world
are they gonna bring back a new for
subtle and Jack Bauer character help
well let me tell you now they don't kill
a lot of people like to try stopping has
it sunk in to you the massiveness of
this franchise I mean I know Kiefer
Sutherland gave you your stamp of
approval I think it's harder for him to
let it go into new hands Jack Bauer is
not done you know the spirit of Jack
Bauer is still in this show
Corey plays Sergeant Eric Carter a
former US Army Ranger who helps take
down a terrorist leader only to find
himself a marked man think of these
people found this it's been the toughest
thing about it the days are long and the
the stunts are real and you know so it
is a lot there but I think mentally
that's the thing literally you have to
be on 24/7 24 was a revolutionary
concept in television when it debuted in
2001 with each season covering a single
24-hour period legacy continues that
tradition it has the same look same
clock and the same ripped from the
headlines stories and only et can bring
you this exclusive scene we were able to
tweet the speech no no it's not about
that you asked me to do a little recon
for you with some of my old media
contacts well one of them came through
so what's different it's a completely
new story you know
new cars the country in the world has
gone through big changes in terms of
what perceived threats are and how
government deals with them there's also
a little more realism this time around
like we'll finally get to see someone he
Eric might have a few seats more than a
few say in the kitchen while he's eating
got to save the world but you got to eat
and don't expect keeper to be making any
cameos as executive producer he's
content
just even quarry advisor keepers just
been an awesome he's the only other
person who really knows what this
particular journey is and the only other
person that I could talk to
I got legacy has a lot to live up to its
predecessor ran nine seasons earned
twenty Emmys and made keepers Jack Bauer
character a household name coin maybe a
familiar face you know him from Straight
Outta Compton but is he ready for all
that
I don't feel it not also don't do this
sort of social social media stuff so I'm
not like no following at all but but my
mom is like sitting and everything
you